the harburg district of hamburg is
dotted with old warehouses made of red
brick
that's also where the restaurant Veloz
is located it's a unique concept instead
of wait staff meals are delivered on
rollercoaster tracks 400 meters long the
serving pots and drinks zoom right to
the table guests place their orders
using a touchscreen monitor for the
euromaxx report a camera was attached to
the tracks and sent on a journey
dena midi come around me fo the camera
went up several times and made its way
spiraling down the roller coaster system
and then it fell down like a fine that's
high he was standing slightly to the
side he's done and suddenly when a bad
fortunately the camera didn't fall on
anyone's head and our your MX reporter
was able to give ordering a meal to try
to
he also interviewed owner Cristian
Steinbach who invested about a million
euros in his restaurant isn't the option
Viacom how did you come up with the idea
for a restaurant where the foods
delivered on a roller coaster i came
across the idea for the first time in
2008 and visited a pilot program in
nuremberg that's what gave me the idea
mr. Holmes depending on demand up to 270
to serving pots are propelled through
the restaurant in one minute a unique
adventure but what made the reports so
popular the steam is honest food is huge
online what with all those people
posting pictures of their food on
Facebook or Twitter a report like this
feeds into that then there's some
technical wizardry of the sort you might
expect from Japan it's a bit like those
crazy germans what are they up to now
zombie are you for open door unless I'm
Jesus two hours good uh the roller
coaster restaurant can't do entirely
without wait staff though hot drinks are
brought to the table in the traditional
fashion it's fun it's amusing you wonder
will it make it will it fall off the
tracks it's different and it's fun
watching your meal fly over the Boston
tolerance was lodged you have to be able
to deal with the neues load with
something constantly rolling along the
tracks it's quite noisy machine apart
from that it's quite rustic and cozy I
want on Suzanne was the column commute
leash
after a long day of filming Matthias
ordered a hearty German meal that before
isn't that so the only question that
still left how does it taste if you live
or die here for my any successful
YouTube format have a presenter a
reporter who explains and tells the
story and that's true of this report to
and probably also accounts for its
success five years later our reporter
recalls what it was like to appear
before the camera except under Stephen
Brandon ah but I don't feel an urge to
do it again it's not my dream when I see
myself through the eyes of someone who
stands behind the camera I think Dana
nagamma episode on coq10 assertions oh
hmm a branch of the restaurant opened in
the Eastern German city of Dresden in
2013 shown here and if you visit the
Europa Park in southwestern Germany or
Abu Dhabi Kuwait or Vienna you can also
get your meals by roller coaster
you